[Música]
una moneda común no es la primera vez en
la historia que se habla sobre este tema
este nuevo intento es propuesto por
Argentina y por Brasil los equipos
económicos de ambos gobiernos trabajan
en una propuesta de una moneda común
para transacciones comerciales el
proyecto desde ya genera varias dudas
por su viabilidad y sería inicialmente
una moneda compartida por estos dos
países Naciones que ya están unidas
comercialmente dentro del marco del
mercosur que se busca entonces con esta
moneda pues evitar la dependencia del
dólar estadounidense que en algunas
ocasiones es difícil para los países de
Suramérica conseguirlo para poder hacer
frente a sus obligaciones
internacionales también eventualmente
podría ser usada para dar paso a una
moneda común en el mercosur que está
conformado no solamente por Argentina y
Brasil sino también por Paraguay y por
Uruguay y también podrían unirse
posteriormente algunos otros países de
la región
en el mundo hay varias regiones que
tienen una moneda compartida ya sea para
usos comerciales o para su curso legal
Es decir para las compras diarias que
hacemos los ciudadanos les mostramos
aquí en el debate de France 24 algunos
de los ejemplos más destacados en África
por ejemplo está el Franco cefa que es
usado por 14 estados de ese continente
la mayoría de ellos son antiguas
colonias francesas además de Guinea
ecuatorial que es o era una colonia
Española y que ha avisado que es una ex
colonia portuguesa El Franco cpf es
usado entre los territorios franceses de
ultramar como la Polinesia francesa
nueva caledonia iguales y futuna que
están todos en el Pacífico en Oceanía
otro ejemplo destacado la libra
esterlina tiene curso legal en los
cuatro países que conforman el Reino
Unido también en las dependencias de la
corona como la isla de Man y las islas
de Jersey en el canal y también los
territorios británicos de ultramar como
bermuda malvinas Gibraltar en donde se
usa una versión local de la libra es
decir como la libra malvinense o la
libra de Santa Elena pero que equivale
Exactamente lo mismo a la libra
esterlina También tenemos que hablar no
muy lejos de nuestra zona el dólar del
Caribe Oriental que es usado por seis
países independientes además de dos
territorios británicos estamos hablando
de anguila y Monserrat es emitido por el
Banco Central del Caribe Oriental que
tiene su sede en la ciudad de vasta que
es la capital de San Cristóbal y Nieves
También tenemos que hablar del euro es
tal vez el ejemplo más reciente que
tenemos de la puesta en marcha de una
moneda común es usada por 17 países de
la Unión Europea además de otros países
como andorra la ciudad del Vaticano
Mónaco y San Marino en donde es la
moneda oficial pero hay que recordar que
estos países no hacen parte de la Unión
Europea también es usado de manera
informal pero se usan todas las
actividades cotidianas diariamente en
kosovo y en Montenegro finalmente el
dólar estadounidense es tal vez la
moneda más ampliamente usada a nivel
internacional para transacciones
comerciales además de Estados Unidos y
de sus diferentes territorios Como por
ejemplo One también el dólar es la
moneda de curso legal por supuesto en
Puerto Rico que es un territorio un
estado libre asociado también en El
Salvador en Panamá Ecuador las Islas
Marshall los estados federados de la
micronesia palautimore Oriental en Asia
las Islas Vírgenes estadounidenses las
Islas Vírgenes británicas y las Islas
tours ancaicos hay otros ejemplos Como
por ejemplo el dólar de Nueva Zelanda el
Ram sudafricano el rublo ruso el dólar
australiano entre otras monedas que son
usadas para simplemente transacciones
comerciales porque hay uniones aduaneras
o comerciales entre algunos países o
también monedas de curso legal como ya
lo decíamos para el uso diario entre sus
habitantes esta Entonces es una
iniciativa esta iniciativa de una moneda
única viable para nuestra región eso
compromete entonces un marco de una
unión aduanera entre los países que
quieran apostarle por esta moneda única
o esta moneda común o esto implicaría la
conformación expansión de un bloque Como
por ejemplo lo estábamos mencionando el
mercosur es necesario entonces que los
países primeros incorporen al mercosur
antes de poder usar una moneda común es
posible entonces tener una moneda única
con unas economías tan dispares e
inestables como las economías de América
Latina pues lo vamos a analizar hoy en
el debate de France 24 para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a Diana
mondino ella es licenciada en economía y
también es profesora de finanzas de la
universidad cema en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires en Argentina le doy la bienvenida
a esta hora y desde la ciudad de Madrid
en España se une Juan Carlos Martínez él
es profesor de entorno económico de ahí
y University allí en la capital española
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
les recuerdo que hacen parte de este
debate pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales ustedes
ya lo saben estamos en Twitter en
Facebook también en Instagram y nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es@santilogo la etiqueta para
que dejen los comentarios es numeral el
debate f24 no olviden también ya para
terminar que todos los contenidos del
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces preguntándole a Diana
nuestra invitada en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires Diana Gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa bienvenida y es
necesario hacer este tipo de esfuerzos
en el momento de las coyunturas
económicas que se están presentando en
América Latina es viable apostarle a una
moneda común como lo están proponiendo
en Brasil y Argentina pero sobra decir
Argentina es el país que está como más
interesado en Brasil hay un poco de
quieren estudiar un poco más con cautela
la propuesta
Mira todos estos procesos son muy largos
los que acabas de contar han llevado
mucho tiempo para que se pueda poner en
marcha el tema de sí es una oportunidad
para ambos países o no Argentina tiene
un enorme déficit fiscal con déficit
Perdón comercial con Brasil el año
pasado Argentina trajo desde Brasil tres
mil seiscientos millones de dólares más
de mercadería que lo que se les vendió
entonces cualquier moneda común que
tiene un desequilibrio entre ambas
partes lo que hay que pensar es qué
haría la persona a la cual le van entre
comillas sobrar esa moneda o el que
tiene necesidad de dónde nos va a
obtener si solamente hay un socio
comercial si esto eventualmente fuera
para incorporar más países ese problema
va desapareciendo se va licuando
entonces yo creo que esto se ha
transmitido como si fuera la posibilidad
de una moneda común
luego se ha hablado de que sería un
comienzo de Unión aduanera que no
tenemos hoy y ahora Aparentemente va a
ser simplemente un crédito que Brasil
otorgaría Argentina por un monto que de
que se indexaría de alguna forma entre
ambas monedas O sea la expectativa
inicial fue muy grande y la realidad en
estas últimas 48 horas ha sido que la
verdaderamente proyectado es bastante
menor es factible sería factible si las
dos economías estuvieran en un
equilibrio similar
pero en Argentina y Brasil por ahora al
menos tenemos fuertes diferencias en la
inflación Argentina tiene un poquito
menos de cien por ciento Brasil
alrededor de diez tenemos un déficit
fiscal muy grande y sobre todo y fuertes
diferencias en las políticas laborales
previsionales comerciales etcétera que
hace que las economías se muevan un
ritmo muy diferente
pero a ver el objetivo de facilitar
costos todo el mundo lo quiere la
pregunta
no hay tiempo todavía de haberla
estudiado es esto realmente reduce
costos O al contrario va a ser una
fricción adicional porque lo que se le
vende a Brasil después no se pueden
utilizar esos recursos para comprar en
otro lado esa parte todavía
está por verse paso a preguntarle a Juan
Carlos a quien también doy la bienvenida
en la ciudad de Madrid en España Juan
Carlos Bienvenido al programa Gracias
por estar con nosotros y desde su punto
de vista es viable esta iniciativa de
una moneda común para para Argentina y
Brasil en el marco de El mercosur
yo creo que no yo creo que no porque
creo que al final una moneda única y
hablo de la experiencia del euro que es
la que conozco muy bien No es otra cosa
que el camino la estación final de un
proceso de integración económica e
incluso de integración política la
económica europea se fundó en 1957 y fue
en 1999 cuando se creó el euro es decir
había ya un recorrido de más de 40 años
de unificación de políticas comerciales
de Unión aduanera incluso de avances en
la unión política digamos que tratar de
construir o crear una moneda única en
este caso entre Brasil y Argentina la
que se pudieran incorporar otros países
sería iniciar un poco la casa por el
tejado y no por los cimientos por qué
porque realmente lo que al menos desde
Europa o al menos desde España nos
resulta muy difícil de entender es cómo
es posible en América Latina que desde
México a Tierra de Fuego no haya sido
posible hasta la fecha crear una especie
de zona de libre comercio una aduanera
hemos visto distintos ejemplos de
integración pero todos que aparecen
desaparecen hemos visto
a instituciones o países que van creando
instituciones que no recorrido tenemos
el mercosur la alianza del pacífico
México con el tlc de Estados Unidos y
Canadá tenemos la comunidad andina de
Naciones es decir tenemos una ropa de
letras y de organizaciones que realmente
Es verdaderamente complicado El pensar
en esa digamos unidad comercial de la
región sin una unidad comercial sin una
coordinación de las políticas
macroeconómicas pensar en una moneda
única como digo es hacer la casa por el
tejado no tendría ningún sentido ni
ninguna viabilidad creo que lo primero
es integrar comercialmente a la región Y
a partir de ahí ya es cuando se podría
empezar a pensar en una moneda única una
vez que las políticas económicas se
coordinasen hoy tal vez la Juan Carlos
es tal vez la deuda pendiente a nivel
histórico que tiene América Latina es
justamente esa integración ya tenemos un
idioma común bueno Brasil habla
portugués pero la mayoría de los países
de Centroamérica y hablan español y ya
hay por lo menos un idioma común y
estamos en pleno 2023 si no hay una
integración ni siquiera dentro de las
subregiones que hay dentro de la región
lo que usted dice en mercosur nunca
terminó despegar la alianza del Pacífico
es muy lenta en su proceso de
integración Centroamérica tampoco lo ha
podido hacer Ahí es donde surge entonces
la pregunta si es necesario este tipo de
anuncios o cómo lo ve usted Diana si
esto simplemente tiene un tinte político
aprovechando el marco de la Cumbre que
tiene lugar en Buenos Aires que es un
tal vez un una forma de mostrar que
Brasil y Argentina vuelven a acercarse
después de esas esos meses o esos años
de estar un poco alejados por las
diferencias políticas que había en entre
los dos países
no me cabe ninguna duda que es un
anuncio puramente político Yo tratando
de ser optimista concuerdo plenamente
con lo que decía Juan Carlos pero
tratando de ser optimista pienso esto
podría obligar a ambas economías hacer
un poco más abiertas O al contrario
vamos a seguir cada día más cerrado
Argentina es una economía extremadamente
cerrada Brasil también y si uno se
limita a comerciar con un solo vecino la
verdad que tiene menos opciones pero
sobre todo que Argentina y Brasil son
economías que a lo largo de los años se
han desarrollado en forma bastante
similar hace 30 años Argentina vendía
productos agropecuarios a Brasil hoy
Brasil no solo nos compra poco sino que
está en condiciones de exportar gran
parte de los mismos productos teníamos
una complementariedad en la industria
Automotriz ahora la industria brasilera
ya no es una industria que necesita
componentes o partes que solamente las
puede obtener Argentina para nada
entonces estar ligado solamente a un
socio limita muchísimo las opciones de
todas maneras aunque así no fuera la
diferencia de tamaño comercial Argentina
debe mucho a Brasil
dónde obtendría Argentina los recursos
para poder pagar a Brasil Por eso yo
creo que este es un un anuncio que fue
distorsionado todos tenemos tantas ganas
de que las economías empiecen a abrirse
al mundo de que dejen de pelear
políticamente que entonces esta posible
integración política y posible apertura
al mundo la verdad que estuvo muy buena
recepción Pero hay otros temas técnicos
no ha habido ningún estudio por parte de
los bancos centrales de cómo sería esto
no ha habido consultas a los sectores
empresarios o sindicatos de cómo
funcionaría esto claro por lo tanto si
ocurriera sería impuesto por los
gobiernos y quién sabe cómo resultaría
esto es muy prematuro pensar que se
pueda llegar una moneda común Yo creo
que ni siquiera vamos a llegar a una
unidad de cuenta para fines comerciales
que lo digo en términos muy simples es
como anotar en un cuaderno yo te debo a
ti tú me debes a mí o sea ni eso vamos a
lograr hacer
ya vamos a hablar de cómo sería ese
proceso o por lo menos Cuáles son los
estudios y los factores que hay que
tener en cuenta para poder comenzar a
pensar en una moneda común Quiero
preguntarle a Juan Carlos sobre la
experiencia que hay del euro lo que uno
ve por lo menos desde este lado del
Atlántico es que es una moneda que ha
sido exitosa en su puesta en marcha sí
les tocó les tomó mucho tiempo ponerla
en curso casi 35 años hasta el día que
entró en funcionamiento pero vemos como
representa un factor de estabilidad para
países que están aspirando a mejorar sus
economías y que también le apuestan al
proyecto europeo vimos recientemente que
Croacia se incorporó plenamente a la
Unión Europea y adoptó la moneda cosa
que no han hecho otros miembros que
llevan un poco más de tiempo
incorporados en esa Unión la experiencia
en esencia para usted del euro es
exitosa es el euro en caso de éxito de
una moneda común
desde mi punto de vista sin ninguna duda
es un auténtico éxito que en este
momento haya 20 países que utilizamos la
misma moneda que comerciamos en la misma
moneda y que y que encima esos número de
países vaya a incorporarse en los
próximos años de hecho hablabas hay
países como kosovo Bosnia que están
nebulizados yo creo que ha facilitado
los intercambios comerciales ha
facilitado las transacciones nos
facilita la vida a los europeos cuando
nos movemos y pero como digo al final es
una historia de éxito que no ha estado
exenta de problemas el haber hecho una
unidad monetaria no ha sido sencillo y
lo vimos durante la crisis de 2000 la
crisis financiera los años 10 12 que el
euro tuvo problemas hubo riesgo incluso
de que algún país como Grecia abandonase
el euro Pero porque es muy importante
para tener una moneda única tener una
cierta afinidad macroeconómica tener una
convergencia macroeconómica donde los
países digamos tienen parámetros o
trabajan en tener parámetros
macroeconómicos similares eso es la
clave de bóveda de tener una moneda
única y eso es lo que hoy es
absolutamente imposible de encontrar en
América Latina no solamente esa sopa de
letras de distintos procesos de
integración regional sino también
economías absolutamente distintas desde
el punto de vista macroeconómico
economías que no tiene nada que ver pues
hablaba mi compañera del desajuste
fiscal o de la inflación en Argentina
con la inflación bueno quizá ahora está
elevada en todos los países pero que
antes del covid podías encontrar en
chile o en Perú el grado de apertura de
esas economías no es lo mismo el grado
apertura de chile que el grado de
apertura de mercosur que es una es una
asociación muy cerrada al exterior
realmente son muchas las cosas que hacen
que yo creo que hoy sea inviable ese
proceso el euro para mí es una historia
de éxito pero es una historia de euro
que hay que una historia de éxito que
hay que seguir trabajando todos los días
en esa coordinación de las políticas
macroeconómicas sin esa convergencia
macroeconómica es muy difícil que una
moneda tenga éxito sí sobre todo cuando
hay un desbalance económico cuando hay
países tan grandes económicamente
hablando como por ejemplo Alemania o
Francia o los Países Bajos y hay países
con unas economías todavía con muchas
problemas después de haber pasado por
gobiernos socialistas o comunistas como
es justamente el caso de Croacia que se
que se ha incorporado recientemente y le
ha costado mucho también por ejemplo los
países bálticos lograr llegar a los
estándares para poder adoptar el euro
sin embargo lo han hecho de manera
exitosa a pesar de las dificultades
Diana en este caso y en esta coyuntura
que nos trae esta este proyecto o esta
propuesta de una moneda común también
vale la pena hacer una evaluación de
cómo está el mercosur en este momento
una una organización de tipo comercial
de estos países del Sur que se politizó
mucho qué usted ahora del mercosur esto
puede servir de pronto como un un nuevo
Punto de partida o un una un una forma
de refrescar El mercosur para ponerlo a
andar con esas bases con las que se
apostaban en los años 90
a ver el mercosur está agonizando fue
pensado con un mundo muy diferente con
unas necesidades del mundo muy
diferentes y con una capacidad
productiva de los países que no ha
crecido al ritmo en generar
competitividad en generar integración en
cumplir con protocolos de sanitarios que
tienen en el resto del mundo hoy el
mercosur en vez de facilitar en comercio
entre los países que que conforman lo
que hace es dificultar el comercio con
otros países es lo que se llama
desviación de comercio se vende dentro
del mercosur porque para comprar o
vender a otros países se han subido
tantos los impuestos normalmente una
Unión aduanera significa que entre los
países hay menos restricciones lo que
mercosur hizo es poner más restricciones
hacia los demás
Entonces no hemos tenido esas ventajas
de habernos solucionado Por otra parte
tenemos estructuras productivas muy
similares en el sector agropecuario es
lo más importante en los países del
mercosur las necesidades de los tipos de
consumo de la población son muy
similares por lo tanto la única forma
que habría de de mejorar esta relación
es que alguno de los países fuera
extremadamente competitivo
extremadamente eficiente Y ninguno lo es
pero sobre todo Argentina que yo estoy
en Argentina no lo es porque tiene una
extraordinaria carga impositiva o fiscal
Y eso hace muy difícil si esto se
revitalizar el mercosur y es para hacer
más eficiente dentro del mercosur ojalá
se logre si En cambio es para seguir
haciendo más difícil vender a otros
países del mundo y poner restricciones
la verdad
que solamente causaría un perjuicio
claro
y Juan Carlos su punto de vista que
evaluación hace usted de El mercosur Y
cómo serían esos primeros pasos que
debería de dar la región de América
Latina de Cara a poder tener una moneda
común es primero entonces necesario una
Unión aduanera primero
mejor hacer una creación de un mercado
común ir eliminando aranceles ustedes
son los expertos les doy la palabra Juan
Carlos
Bueno es un poco lo que lo que veníamos
hablando mercosur es una organización
muy proteccionista de cara al exterior y
de hecho mercosur es un bloque que se ha
preocupado de comerciar internamente
pero no de abrirse a otros ahora tenemos
ese tratado de libre comercio entre
mercosur y la Unión Europea que lleva
negociándose cuánto casi 20 años y que
no acaba de concretarse y que una vez
que ha sido aprobado Ahora tiene que ser
ratificado y llevamos ya tiempo en ello
Es verdaderamente complejo y en el fondo
subyace lo que decía mi compañera mucho
proteccionismo Brasil es un país muy
proteccionista Argentina es un país muy
proteccionista en estos momentos Uruguay
quiere firmar un acuerdo de libre
comercio con china quiere abrirse al
exterior quiere evitar esas barreras que
decía no solo comerciamos entre nosotros
y dificultamos el comercio con el
exterior pues Uruguay lo quiere hacer
con china Pero eso mercosur no se lo
permite Lo cual hay genera ese conflicto
al final volvemos a esa fragmentación
del comercio regional latinoamérica es
una región que comercia muy poco entre
entre ellos aproximadamente
15-18% de las exportaciones
latinoamericanas son intrarregionales
cuando en Europa estamos hablando de
niveles en torno al 60 70 por ciento por
tanto son países o sois países que
comeráis muy poco entre entre ellos
mismos y que encima se están bastante
cerrados que por ejemplo Argentina que
chile tenga tratados de libre comercio
con multitud de países Pero en cambio no
lo tenga con Argentina que comparte con
frontera a través de la Cordillera es
algo verdaderamente difícil de entender
desde Europa no que te vayas a buscar
acuerdos comerciales con países a los
que a veces es difícil encontrar en el
mapa pero que no tengas un acuerdo libre
comercio con mercosur este es el gran
problema la falta de integración
regional desde el punto de vista
comercial sería el primer paso después
la integración económica o la
coordinación económica y la moneda única
llegaría pues mucho tiempo después de
haber trabajado en esos en esos aspectos
Por eso yo creo que esto ha sido Pues un
anuncio una ocurrencia de que es algo
que vendría bien pero que realmente yo
creo que todos los que y los propios
miembros del gobierno argentino de
gobierno brasileño se han dado cuenta
que esto es una entelequia y que hoy por
hoy es absolutamente inviable hay muchas
cosas que hacer antes de crear una
moneda única en este caso entre
Argentina Brasil o en el conjunto de la
región además entra También en disputa
esta soberanía monetaria que tanto están
los países dispuestos a cerrar sus
bancos centrales acceder la soberanía a
otro país o a un conjunto de países para
tener una moneda común vemos el caso por
ejemplo de Ecuador El Salvador y Panamá
que son economías dolarizadas no
convendría dolarizar la región no sería
más fácil unificar todo el continente
americano con con el dólar
estadounidense que es la moneda como lo
decía de mayor curso y e intercambio a
nivel comercial en la zona pues
finalmente Estados Unidos es
económicamente el país más importante
del continente es nuestro referente en
muchas cosas a nivel comercial es el
país con el que más comerciamos además
de China pero es es muy importante para
la región no convendría para el
continente Diana dolarizar
a ver habría que empezar por no tener
déficit fiscal porque los países con
déficit fiscal y Argentina es el campeón
mundial lo que hacen es imprimir dinero
tu Banco Central está al servicio de lo
que necesita el gobierno por lo tanto
eso tendría que desaparecer y es un
desafío político muy muy grande en
cuanto a dorarizar es ahí políticamente
mucho resquemor pero francamente lo
facilitarían Y si te fijas en
Latinoamérica el uso de bitcoin por
ejemplo como tiene El Salvador
Está bueno ahí ya es moneda de curso
legal pero en muchos países
latinoamericanos es extremadamente usado
la gente no quiere tanto su propia
moneda y quiere algo que le permita
comerciar con el resto del mundo la
verdad que dolarizar o alguna otra
opción que impida que los gobiernos
tengan la flexibilidad que están
teniendo ahora para para cambiar Yo sé
que para flexibilidad suena como algo
positivo pero en realidad termina
generando inflación sin embargo Y fíjate
un caso por ejemplo Perú que ha tenido
enormes problemas políticos en todos los
últimos años y ahora evidentemente
también Simplemente porque tiene un
Banco Central que se comporta en una
forma muy recta no está teniendo
problemas propiamente de inflación
si latinoamérica se dolarizará dejando
de lado los temas políticos tendría que
comenzar a tener una cada país un estado
más eficiente y la verdad que sí crear
una moneda común como decía Juan Carlos
llevaría 30 años lograr estados
eficientes en Latinoamérica no sé cuánto
tiempo nos llevará pero es un tema que
es tabú en este momento Diana eso me me
trae un poco a la memoria el caso de
Argentina en los 90 cuando tenían
paridad entre el peso argentino y el
dólar pero justamente Esto empezó a
venirse abajo no sé si el propósito del
gobierno argentino en ese momento era
dolarizar en un futuro la economía
Argentina pero justamente esto se vino
abajo porque el Banco Central argentino
empezó a imprimir más y la inflación en
Argentina empezó a incrementarse y pues
claramente el peso ya no podía sostener
una paridad con el dólar es así o es mi
mala memoria sobre este episodio de la
economía Argentina de los tantos que ha
habido
es parecido a Argentina efectivamente no
emitió dinero pero sí tenía una enorme
nivel de endeudamiento y para tener ese
nivel de endeudamiento necesitabas
pagarlo básicamente en dólares para lo
cual necesitabas abrir más rápido la
economía para que se exportara más y
tener más dólares y ese proceso fue a
ritmos diferentes no se llegó a tiempo
más los problemas políticos porque hubo
una reducción de gasto muy grande y la
gente que dejó de recibir esos
beneficios públicos por privatizaciones
de empresas etcétera la verdad que hubo
un quiebre en la sociedad que hasta el
día de hoy no solo no se ha subsanado
sino que creo que se ha profundizado
y Juan Carlos retomó la pregunta de la
dolarización usted qué perspectiva tiene
Es sobre este tema y usted como analiza
los casos de estos tres países que han
dolarizado sus economías Ecuador Panamá
que lo hizo ya hace muchísimo tiempo y
El Salvador y Bueno tengo que poner
también sobre la mesa Venezuela que está
prácticamente con una economía de
dolarizada de manera
sin ser oficial pero la economía y la
vida diaria se mueve en dólares allí
la dolarización está bien porque evita
lo que Diana decía antes que el Banco
Central se ponga a financiar el déficit
público genere un exceso de oferta
monetaria que acaba en tasas de
inflación muy altas te da una disciplina
es decir no puedes imprimir dólares
puesto que no tienes la máquina de hacer
dólares esa máquina está en Washington
pero el problema de la dolarización y
Ecuador es un ejemplo perfecto Es que
necesitas tener un flujo de dólares para
poder hacer frente a todos los pagos el
gobierno paga los salarios públicos paga
las pensiones paga el gasto público por
tanto necesita conseguir dólares ahí
está el problema Cómo consigues esos
dólares Panamá de alguna manera juega
con ventaja tiene el canal y el canal es
una fuente de entrada de dólares
absolutamente espectacular El Salvador
tiene las remesas las remesas que recibe
El Salvador en dólares de los aquellos
salvadoreños que están básicamente en
Estados Unidos le ayuda a tener ese
flujo ese flujo de dólares pero pensemos
en el Ecuador Ecuador a pesar de tener
remesas llega momentos sobre todo cuando
el precio del petróleo cae de forma
notoria y eso ocurrió en 2009 ocurrió
hacía a finales del 14 del 15 ocurrió
donde el cuando el covid que Ecuador se
queda sin los dólares que necesita para
poder financiar su economía y cómo
consigue esos dólares es complicado pues
la única forma es a base de
endeudamiento Y entonces es endeudarte
con fondo monetario internacional o
vender la producción de petróleo a
futuro como hizo Correa en el año 2009
para conseguir ese flujo de dólares Si
no tienes entradas de dólares porque
exportando y consigues exportar y con
eso consigues entrar a dólares lo
suficiente remesas o turistas que te
traigan esos dólares o inversión
extranjera tienes un problema el
problema que cada vez que esa entrada de
dólares bajes te pone al borde de la
suspensión de pagos Ese es el gran
problema la dolarización te arregla
algunos problemas en el corto plazo Como
por ejemplo esa hiperinflación que tenía
Ecuador a finales de los 90 que tenía en
su momento Argentina de los 80 porque no
puedes imprimir más no puedes imprimir
la moneda que no es tuya que es el dólar
pero te ata a una situación muy
complicada entrar en la dolarización
como entró el Ecuador como estuvo cerca
de entrar a Argentina al final de los 90
bueno es fácil salir de ella es
prácticamente no digo que imposible pero
sí costosísimo para para cualquier país
de hecho Correa en Ecuador nunca le
gustó la dolarización y él sabía que no
podía abandonarla no con lo cual a mí no
me parece sea una buena solución al
final realmente es decir Bueno adopto
una moneda simplemente para compensar mi
falta de disciplina macroeconómica mi
falta de disciplina fiscal ni falta de
disciplina monetaria y yo creo que ese
no es el camino lo que tienes que
conseguir es esa disciplina fiscal y
monetaria y Diana ponía el perfecto
ejemplo del Perú probablemente pocos
países en Latinoamérica llevan unos años
con mayor turbulencia política pero
gracias a una política muy seria de su
Banco Central del señor Velarde Pues el
sol es una moneda estable y no tiene las
turbulencias que otros países con más
irurrencias económicas que otros países
con más estabilidad política están
teniendo Sí aquí lo hemos analizado aquí
en el debate de France 24 hemos hablado
sobre es impresionante estabilidad que
presenta Perú después de una pandemia
toda la inestabilidad política y la
economía se mantiene a flote
relativamente en calma a pesar de la
turbulencia y se mantiene incluso
recibiendo buena inversión extranjera
que también eso llama la atención dado
el escenario político que que presenta
vamos llegando ya al bloque final de el
programa quiero que hagamos entonces las
conclusiones de lo que nos deja esta
propuesta
esta idea de tener una moneda común por
lo menos iniciando en el marco del
mercosur entre Argentina y Brasil si
esto es viable Y si claramente lo que
deja esto en evidencia es la
indisciplina fiscal y económica de los
países latinoamericanos y esa falta de
integración regional que sigue siendo
una deuda pendiente vuelvo y lo digo
comienzo Entonces por Diana y dejó a
Juan Carlos para el cierre ya en
adelante
Pues sí pues justamente muestra todo eso
que decías y muestra el temor que tienen
estos gobiernos a abrir la economía Por
qué vender solo a un país y no a todos
aquellos que puedan o quieran comprar
muestra también la necesidad de hacer
fuegos artificiales de política para
decir que va a haber algún beneficio y
tenemos cantidad de ejemplos en donde
Buscar la solución mágica ni para hacer
dieta a las personas ni para hacer dieta
a los gobiernos pueden funcionar
solamente con aumento de productividad
abrir la economía y mejorar todos los
indicadores que mencionaba Juan Carlos
al principio recién ahí los países
pueden crecer en forma sostenida y que
la población viva mejor
y Juan Carlos su conclusión para el
cierre mi conclusión es que ojalá la
integración económica la integración
regional tomar a cuerpo de una vez por
todas en Latinoamérica antes hablabas de
esa lengua común el español o el
portuñol que hablan los portugueses esa
cultura común latinoamérica es la región
del planeta que en teoría lo tiene más
fácil para esa integración comercial A
diferencia de Europa
1957 se creó la comunidad económica
europea solamente 12 años después del
fin de la Segunda Guerra Mundial que
todos sabemos lo que supuso y allí
estuvieron los que habían estado en
bandos enfrentados Latinoamérica lo
tiene todo a favor y no ha sido capaz de
avanzar en la integración regional
Europa lo tenía todo en contra y lo ha
hecho quizá Esa es la gran lección que
debe sacar latinoamérica dejar de un
lado la ideología la rivalidades y
pensar en esa integración comercial en
ese mercado que puede ser
empieza en México acabe en Tierra de
Fuego y que facilite esos intercambios
comerciales que facilite una
coordinación de las políticas
macroeconómicas y que algún día pueda
ser tener como colofón una moneda única
es que vemos el caso de África lo
mencionaba yo el Franco cefa que une a
14 países
francófonos y a un país hispanoparlante
y un luso parlante en en África y lo
tuvieron fácilmente por esta integración
lingüística y ahí más avances en
integración en esos 14 países africanos
que solemos mirar a África por encima
del hombro y ellos nos están dando ahí
una lección y es una moneda que ya lleva
muchísimo tiempo a pesar de la de lo que
genera en torno al pasado colonial sin
duda alguna es una deuda pendiente
veremos Entonces esta propuesta como se
desarrolla en los próximos días en las
próximas semanas y qué conclusiones
dejan este encuentro de la celac en
Buenos Aires donde fue presentada esta
idea y si otros países pues se muestran
interesa en esta moneda común para la
región de América Latina o por lo menos
en el mercosur a Diana y a Juan Carlos
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros haber hecho este análisis
interesante para la audiencia de France
24 de habernos puesto en palabras muy
simple estos temas económicos para
entender lo que están proponiendo los
presidentes de Brasil y Argentina
ustedes Muchísimas gracias por la
sintonía En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos por haber estado con
nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera Muchas gracias Pueden
seguir dejando los comentarios a través
de las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]